securing modern web applications can be
a challenge
with an escalating number of threats
having to manage multiple vendors and
point products
and an increasingly high standard of
security expected by your customers
google cloud simplifies all of that by
giving you comprehensive protection
through a suite of proven google
technology all managed from a single
interface
protecting some of the most prolific
internet properties such as google
search
gmail and youtube has led google to
develop advanced and sophisticated
protections
which you can now leverage for your web
applications and apis
implement an industry standard web
application firewall with granular ip
and geo-based controls and defend
against prevalent attacks
such as denial of service cross-site
scripting
and sql injection protect your web app
from fraudulent activity and abuse
with google cloud you have access to
intelligent fraud and bot detection
services
with an adaptive risk analysis engine
assessing the needs of your business
and rich telemetry you can easily
protect from scraping
credential stuffing automated account
creation and exploits from automated
bots
integrations can be another point of
weakness with google cloud
you can secure your apis in minutes
out-of-the-box policies enable
developers to
augment apis with features to control
traffic enhance performance
and enforce security
meet the challenge of securing modern
web applications with google cloud's web
app and api protection
if you want to learn more about this
solution watch a webinar
or read a white paper go to g dot co
cloud slash waap